我給大家分享一下普通人到底該怎麼賺錢
從今天開始我準備把它變成一個系列
偶爾就給大家講普通人到底該怎麼賺錢
是一套玩任務的方法論
就免費了
你也不曉得包括你也不到我這叫多少錢
或者我怎麼跟你學不曉
我就是免費的跟你分享
然後你可以承受
但是記住一定要去承受
我借責辦法幾乎都沒有承辦
就是你做了
你什麼也不會哭一但是你承受了
那就是承受了
而且你只要做了就一定有收益
首先我給大家花一張地圖
我們必須指出我們大多數人的問題
和卡帶成的地方了
首先第一個的話就我們很原認為
就是我我想中前先搞個服務
服務業就是我能我的月威勢去幹一個事
我告訴你這個想法是有問題的
為什麼有問題我後面的詳細講
第二個問題第二個是什麼呢
就是我們很原就是我要提升我的氣氛
然後可以拿到工夫的工資
我不走這兩頭多
我想給它做另外兩個另外的一頭
而是一個真正的專前的方法
而且不要簡單的
什麼呢就是
十別發現你生活中的問題
然後把它提供一套我就就翻
這個你放心這個不是那麼符達的很簡單
叫我的方法做很簡單
然後你一定用港港的方式把它放到
很多說很簡單對很簡單
最關鍵的問題是你去做
我們很久的最大的問題是第一個就是
我一定要想明白的來做
萬一我失敗他怎麼辦
他有多少頭頭頭頭什麼什麼什麼什麼
什麼樣子的問題我就講了
講了第二個第二就是說什麼都不願意動手
就是我們很多人的問題
還怕失敗這是很多人的問題
其實在弄作一下很簡單
然後不廢話了
那麼我剛才說什麼來的
普通人真正有的方法是什麼
發現十別一個問題
然後提供一個可行的絕端
然後開始是用港港大量的複製它
真正的卡點在哪
卡點就是怎麼發現問題
就是我一開始入門一起動從哪兒起動從哪入門
對吧你看我一講一說通點怎麼怎麼入
怎麼痛
從哪開始啊
我給大家講一個方法
就是發現問題一般來說是兩塊
兩種方法一方法
第一種方法是什麼呢就是
生活中的摩擦地
就是要不然就是讓這個東西太符達
太符達了就真難搞還在讓我去思考
然後還有就是這個當我等待身體太長了太髮了
對吧還有在什麼時候通過太匯了
其實有什麼那就不要讓我想
不要讓我等
不要讓我花那麼多錢
比較給讓我花錢
這是摩擦點
第二個部分是人們的就是新商
新商是什麼呢首先就是我不知道
我好多證了我還不知道
就在我知道了都買了
對吧或者是我知道了以後我也看不懂
這個永遠存在
這個永遠存在比如說現在的什麼
什麼龍蝦呀對啊
都是有這個問題吧
好這就是幾個兩個最大的點
然後具體給它怎麼做呢我給大家局警個信息以後的話呢我會
就是把那個若果點一共一共一共一共跟進財政案裡面就可以碰出來
但是這個就像是總幹
是陳進彈
比如說第一個方法是什麼呢就是你從工作中發現一些問題
很多人比如说我就工厌层抱歉你没有时间
其实最简单的方法就是从你的工作中发现
就是那种让我党的让我反的
对吧就是看不懂的
路上太复杂的对吧
或者花钱太贵的意思了
我举个例子
其实每个地方对我这个这个点比如说很转转会接受一些
可能比如说电话克服
竟然会有人打电话过来对吧
中文问问挺危险的问题
因为搞不懂了 危险搞不懂了
你们那个说明太复杂了
为什么太复杂了
因为我我也不知道到底你遇到那些问题
对不对
举个很简单的例子有一个人要单点
有一个人要单点
他是远马逊的
他在远马逊的时候就发现经常有人问问题
而且有些问题是
他两个出现重复的出现
你看像我们的反色 对不对
但他发现欧洲这些问题重复的出现
他就按照右线能力把重复出现最多的问题
然后按照右线能力 接受解释的方案 接受解释的方案
然后他就把他写成了一个杂制吧
就是一个藍木吧 对不对
叫什么如何更好的事务加码训
这个一上线低年卖了五十万美金
你看就是发现
工作中生活中人们经常暴回那边
主持人物过你在你在工作前 经常会遇到跟他暴回
对吧
那么你就可以把他变成一个
SOP呀
一个魔法吧
什么的 对吧
第二种方式是什么的
你自己的买过什么东西
你消费过什么东西 这个东西是不是你也可以做
或者中间有什么卡电
九例子 你买东西的时候你说查了好多好多次的
才决定要买什么 那你买个时候你做了什么样的新的东西
你才决定要买它或者是你买的过程中
就是买回来以后又遇到什么的问题
很难受的问题 或者是你越别把这个东西介绍给别人
如果是不为什么 这里面其实玩的时候决定买
有一个成员就开了一千的时候
用这个影响笔记 影响笔记的话能稳拿他们简单
只有最简单的这些文章
但是照影响笔有很多高级的种法 这些人都不会
他认识是公司嘛 然后他就发现
可以这么做 可以这么做
他就把这个东西写成的文章 写成的部分就发着这的
好来好多人说 你把那个部分的那么张力出来就张力出来的
叫他印象笔记之南
结果呢 上限是一天 买了一万美金 一年大概买12万美金
这个事是不成不出现的 后来又出现的东西
有人用东西 用团的方法寄错
最近又出现了东西 又出现了AI
对吧
是什么事 这个世界总是存在的
就是我在做的公众 这有卡点 这有卡点 这有卡点
对吧
或者这三种有时候我正常有的兴趣
就是我在做兴趣的公众 我在做
做我喜欢做的事 中间可能会有些卡点
或者我有一个什么绝对 反映我爸的 我爸的分享说
对吧 这种方法是非常非常多的 而且
我在给大家打破一个思路 就是我们很久没在做事 说总想的是
就是我测试干 我没时间干 我告诉你
你们时间是最好的事 而且你现在有工作
其实没时间是最好的事 为什么 我来解释一下 首先第一个你
那个工作 有人跟提供兴趣水 说明那个工作是有价值
你好像在家里的那 那可能就是你的收益
然后你的公司 现在那个你发现水 说明的公司在市场中是有价值的
你的公司到底提供什么
那个价值是什么 卡点都是什么 哪个地方可以改进 这可能都是
收益点 你是离市场最近的人
你是离市场最近的人 而且你很容易就发现
就是很多黑箱什么 别人不知道 但是你就打 而且你会发现
还有人能给你提供兴水
对吧 而且早期的时候其实全家店的过程不需要你全家一会
而且我告诉你 如果你没时间做更好了 为什么
因为你没时间就因为你没有办法做那么多功能
而实际上做产品 根本不是做更多功能
而是解决最重要的问题
所以它的逼换你去解决真正重要的问题
所以好像说我要去试试 试 试试 试试
其实是在工作的时候去解决这个问题就是
最好的 所以各位
我教大家两方方 两部两部一定要做的 第一部就是
每天就要养成10遍
就是生活中的一些摩托小点
别人抱怨的点 对吧 比如说那个
等待时间谈 太长了 这个东西他要付了杂亚
这个东西就要花这么多很太贵了
有这个摩托小点 全部
只要你发现有人抱怨 你次用了过程中的抱怨 就把它记得起来
然后长时的给他解决方案 如果你想要从这些工程中好了 第二件事情
你待遇到这样的摩托小点 一定要把它记住下来
什么摩托小点 怎么解决
别人接着是什么 还记得吗 就别人一张支持快篇
然后各位 如果你还有另外一个好喜欢就好了
就是每天写点什么 每天拍头视频 每条粉丝 每天长时粉丝再见
你会发现这就是你
收一的来源 各位 还记得吗 就是普通人最好的
赚钱的方法是什么 就是
发现失别问题
然后提供一个提供方案 然后利用港澳
把它放大